foreign
is finalized I have 50 50. I am owing
her still child support I still have to
pay for child care on my side she could
work but she's not and because you
entered into a legal Arrangement the
disillusion of that legal Arrangement
put the here's what's going to happen in
the hands of a government official
[Music]
John with the doctor John Malone's show
and we are partying today that's not
true at all actually we're not parting
even a little bit but we are taking you
calls
about the things that are going on in
your life on the greatest mental health
and marriage and parenting whatever
podcast exercise nutrition whatever's
going on in your world we got you
right here on the show uh if you want to
be on the show give me a buzz
1-844-693-3291 it's
1-844-693-3291 or go to John delaney.com
ask and huge dude you guys are showing
up with the five star reviews the guy
here named Eric he's an incredible guy
he manages all the podcast stuff
whatever that means and he came down I
was like what have you all done man we
just got this influx of reviews thank
you thank you thank you thank you thank
you keep hitting the Subscribe button
it's a huge help to your neighbors
because it helps kick this show up so
they can get it too
um and if there's an episode that you
think you know what my mother-in-law
needs to hear this send it send it for
sure that will cheer me up and it will
destroy your Thanksgiving so way to go
all right let's go to
Caitlyn in Pittsburgh what's up Caitlyn
hey John what's up yeah I'm just
yeah I just have a question
well cool bring it on I'm I'm just
trying to get through the call right now
so
it's trying to get through the cold
I'm trying to get through this call
without my body taking off on me so yeah
I got you I got you okay all right hey
do me a favor okay
um yeah take the deep as deep a breath
as you possibly can and hold it all
right okay do it real quick take it real
deep
hold it one
two
three blow it out as hard as you can
okay and then your shoulders are up as
tight as they can be around your ears
drop them pull your hands down as far as
you can to the floor okay
okay cool now we're in it so what's up
all right thanks thank you
so beginning of this year I started to
pursue healing on my own shot her
childhood trauma I'm actually reading
this because I knew I had to read it you
got it you hate read it read away that's
cool
with that I've experienced depression
and time where I emotionally you know
pretty much checked out
um the area where I really struggle with
is in motherhood okay and if all times
get home mom I fear I put trauma on them
I take all their behavior issues or when
I feel they're hurting as my fault like
emotional and hurting or um when I see
the emotionally struggling
um and I find myself sometimes not
intervening you know scrabbles or a
fight because I feel like I don't know
what to do or I'm just too exhausted to
follow through I just want to find my
joy in motherhood again okay when did
you when did you feel it leave
um probably after the second to youngest
how many do you have
four
how old are what's the oldest
eight eight seven six and one good
box of bananas that was me trying not to
swear I don't know where that
um
Caitlyn that's a whole whole lot
yeah
um
tell me about this latest one
foreign was the latest one planned or
was it a hey look what we have here yes
yes he was yeah yeah which one
the latest they were
all there yes okay all right
um so when when did what happened that
you suddenly felt the joy of motherhood
just leaving you
I guess I'm not sure
um I know after the second thing and
this I did suffer some to put a Spartan
depression okay as well as with their
youngest but um yeah are you married
yes tell me about that
um he's a great guy I mean
yeah I love him he's he's a very very
awesome dad to the kids okay
tell me about your marriage
it's I mean I that's good I mean I we
definitely could improve on connection
on connecting with each other better or
or
um
um what's the word to use
like like
um
I can't think of the word right now but
here's here's what happens often in the
situation you're describing is one
person is is either struggling or down
regulated a little bit or just feeling a
little bit heavy
and another the other partner steps in
and helps and is really wonderful and
it's both life-giving and it's a teeny
tiny bit
shameful like I I it's like I should be
doing that or how can he or she do that
and I just can't do it and that call
causes us to pull back a little bit more
and then that person fills in the Gap a
little bit more and suddenly we've
created a dance that's that's it's hard
we end up co-managing our household but
we're not we're great business partners
but we're not married
you see what I'm saying and I'm not
saying that's happening that's what I'm
trying to get at
has your body found yourself surrounded
by a whole bunch of people and you are
completely alone that's what I'm getting
at uh-huh yeah yeah is that right okay
tell me about this childhood trauma you
experienced
it was
sick okay how old were you
um over a period of years
when did it start
around the age of six or so okay
um
who is who is who is
who is the evil person in your life
my dad okay
I'm sorry
I know you know this but that shouldn't
happen I'm sorry
yeah yeah just this morning and I was
writing out your question it came to me
about
could it be that I have fear
that I'm going to be hurting my kids as
well and I you know I don't know but
that's something that came to my mind
this morning as I was writing the
question out
um I think any of those things that pop
into your mind are worth asking
um
without meeting you this is total total
conjecture okay my guess is
um or if I was if I just met you we just
had the conversation we've had and I was
to place a bet my bet would be that your
body
has recognized there's an eight and a
seven and a six-year-old in your home
and it recognizes that story
and
it'll be damned if it happens again and
it becomes hyper Vigilant all the time
in protection of those three little kids
and you put that level of
um say sympathetic arousal but you put
that level of a brain that is on high
alert high high high alert
and then you dump a one-year-old into
that
and then you dump right and you see what
I'm saying so all of a sudden your body
is vacillating between It's At War and
then it's got to shut the system down or
it's going to crash and it's just this
constant toggle and it's hard to be in a
relationship with that kind of person
struggling that way and it's hard to be
in a relationship when you are
struggling that way and then you find
yourself more and more isolated yet more
and more busy and more and more lonely
surrounded by more and more people
and you feel like you're going insane
am I right or wrong tell me where I'm
right and tomorrow I'm wrong
no yeah that
that's about how it would be yeah okay
so the the magic is not the magic it's
not magic at all the gnarly gritty
healing work is letting your body feel
there's a six-year-old in the house
there's a seven-year-old there's an
eight-year-old in the house and
foreign
because they have me as their mom
and my my dad was the worst of the worst
of the worst but their dad is not
my dad was evil their dad's safe
and we're gonna practice feeling our
bodies when it starts to take off on us
on us and then we're going to practice
re-taking control of the thoughts that
we have
and then we're going to do the really
hard work which is
right data letter that you're never
going to send him
and let him know
how I hurt you and how that's ricocheted
through your life
you'll write another letter to them let
him know what he's missed
then you're going to write them another
letter that says hey by the way this
stopped here
because I've got four beautiful
incredible kids and I'm a damn good mom
and just to put a cherry on top I'm a
great wife too
I'm a good friend
see what I'm saying
yes yes
and then you've got to do the harder
hard hard stuff which is you got to take
care of yourself you got to be around
people and you got to laugh and you have
to exercise and you gotta sleep and you
gotta eat right and you have to give
yourself some Grace because you have a
freaking one-year-old in your in your
house right which is like just pulling a
grenade every morning just rolling it
into the living room and saying yeah
let's see what explodes today
how does that all sound sound like
bullcrap or does it sound right what
tell me what you're tell me what you're
feeling
I don't know
I mean yeah
it all sounds good I mean I've been you
know working through this journey for
the past no well beginning of the year
it's when I started
and um yeah
um
I'm gonna give you a really awful
analogy but it's the most recent one in
my life is that okay
yeah okay
um I was on a trip
um this past weekend with my son and
some men that I trust and love and their
boys and we went on this Texas hunting
trip and it's every bit if when you hear
the words Texas hunting trip it was all
of it okay
and the very first night the boy the old
men we were sitting on the on a rocking
chair out on the front porch of this
metal building in the middle of nowhere
no running water or anything and the
boys are running around with flashlights
being silly and one of the boys trips on
the fire pit
and just blast his shin on it it
explodes
okay
um whenever we saw him in the light we
took him inside looked in the light and
the moment I saw it is like some he's
got to go to the hospital right now
and it was a gnarly gnarly cut and his
dad I stayed with the boys his dad took
him to the emergency room with another
friend of ours
and in the ER
they took that cut and they gave him
some medicines that he couldn't feel the
pain
but then they had to take out this
sandpapery scrub brush
and clean the wound
and my buddy said he had to sit down and
he and because he started getting woozy
because it was an already violent scene
and it became the healing process the
initial healing was really brutal
okay
and then that allowed them to do the
first layer of stitches and then close
it up and then do the top layer of
stitches and within 24 hours that little
boy was running around again
when you're healing from trauma
the initial part of the journey is very
empowering I write these letters I feel
good like I feel like I'm taking control
I weep heavily I call family I call
friends I have this moment
and then we recognize how deep that
wound is and how much it's affected
other things
and then starts the grinding process the
real painful part the part where we wish
it hadn't happened and I can't believe
you did this and then I've made
decisions in my life out of pain out of
hiding out of fear and I've hurt people
and people have hurt me and and you've
got to get through that grinding
sandpaper process so that
the healing can happen in a clean way on
the back end and that feels like where
you are and then you threw a
one-year-old baby in the middle of it
all
right which is just hard and then you've
got a six and seven eight year old
that's reminding your body what you've
been through before
that means this is front and center here
this isn't like you had sexual childhood
childhood sexual abuse and you're single
and you're 25 and you're spending time
with a therapist and spending time in a
group you spend time with your friends
you are living this out you are changing
the oil on your car while you're driving
it's a very complex task that you've
undertaken and it's right
it's good it's just going to be hard and
when it's hard and when it's messy when
you don't feel full like you're at the
very tip top your Tank's not full that's
okay
the person who should have taught you
that you're okay
took everything from you when you were a
kid
right
yeah and so now you've got to do the
hard work of relearning wait a minute
man I do have value I am worthy of being
loved I am a good mom
you're not going to re-traumatize your
kids Hon you're just not
unless you abuse them which you're not
going to do no letting an eight and a
six and a seven-year-old squabble and
figure stuff out that's great
it's great I over get involved in my
kids
and every time I do it I think gosh I
just need to let them work this out
so you're doing great
I'd love to see you and your husband
um
take a marriage Retreat together just
you too get away for a weekend and
recalibrate because now you got four
humans that you're responsible for in
addition to yourself
so your needs have shifted your needs
have changed your life has changed your
sleep is goofed up your exercise is all
good everything's goofed up
and so it's not about trying to get back
to what was it's trying to create
something new and at the same time
you're becoming a different person
you're healing you're standing you're
going to stand six inches taller when
this thing's over
keep working with your counselor
keep hanging in there I'm gonna send you
all the questions for humans cards for
kids and I'm going to send you the
questions for humans cards for couples
here's what often happens when someone's
working through a trauma journey and
they're in a long-term relationship
they're married with somebody right or
they already have kids
the idea of human engagement is what
hurt you in the first place
the closest relationship your dad
that's a violation and it becomes this
awful thing where that's the thing
that's going to keep you well as
relationships with other people that's
where your body's gonna settle in so you
can do these other things like Eat Right
exercise sleep all that you you gotta
have that Foundation of being connected
and that's the that's the that's what
hurt you in the first place
and so it's hard to start practicing
being a relationship again that's what
these cards are for deck cards are magic
man
um so I'm gonna send you everything I
got
um with those you can do this with your
kids you can do this with your husband
y'all can get away for a minute stay on
the journey stay on the path you are
doing a great job your kids are lucky to
have you as their mother
and all of us are benefiting from your
bravery thank you for telling your story
we'll be right back
hey guys deloney here and I've got a
word from our sponsor whoop if you've
listened to the show for any length of
time you know I'm a major nerd about
Fitness sleep mental health and building
healthier life habits and let's just say
this whoop makes my nerd heart so happy
one reason I love whoop is that it's not
like all the other fitness trackers that
mix in a watch in laser lights and
smiley faces and a million notifications
and reminders that you you need to get
your steps in no whoop is a fitness
wearable that actually looks cool and
it's comfortable and it gives you data
that really matters it breaks down your
recovery your sleep and your daily
strain into a format that's easy to
interpret and some days I wake up in the
green and this tells me that I'm ready
to go attack the day and other days I
wake up in the red and I know that I
gotta take it easy and I can look back
in time and see how I got there if
you're working to be intentional and
build healthier habits whoop can help
you get there start keeping an eye on
your health and wellness at a deeper
level go to whoop dot com that's
w-h-o-oop.com and use promo code deloni
to get 10 off your order today
all right we're back
um so a few I guess it's a month ago now
by the time this episode's out
um
I launched an episode with my friend Sal
de Stefano from San Jose California he's
part of the Mind pump group uh one of
the one of my most important interviews
I've ever done because I left that
interview and I know you all have
benefited from it I've heard the
feedback it's just been phenomenal
but selfishly I changed how I do my life
on the back end of that interview I said
some things out loud to somebody else
I've never said before I've never talked
about my struggles with with disordered
eating I've never talked about
um I've worked out for 30 years and I
still have always thought I'm screwing
this thing up turns out I was
um my I implemented some things right
when I got home that have had drastic
changes in my life and one of the most
common questions I get from you all is
cool deloni you have an hour every
morning
um to do this long workout and you get
all your stuff in
I don't have that time I've got three
little kids I'm an over the road trucker
I'm a surgeon I just don't have an hour
like whatever it is and so I reached out
to Sal and the Gang and said hey
you guys have something that I can just
tell everybody about and one of the guys
Adam one of my pump guys said hang on
just hang on and then all of a sudden
dude they launched naps 15 which I'm
super jazzed about and I've actually
been working on it and so listen this is
important this is not a advertisement
they didn't pay me I called them okay
um there's no hookup here this is simply
me telling you guys that doing the Mind
pump maps program helped me to help me
become a better dad help me become a
better husband and help me become a
better employee here help me become a
better Citizen and I'm an advocate of
their work there is no money being
exchanged here I'm not making a cent off
of this conversation what I do what I
what I'm committed to is getting you all
things that are going to help you have
better lives and so I called Sal and
said hey would you be on the show talk
about this new program tell everybody
all about it because he's smarter than
me and way smarter than me with this
stuff and I wanted to give you guys a
ringside seat to this new thing that
just hit the marketplace Sal you there
I'm here John what's up homie how we
doing
I'm doing good man thanks for having me
on I appreciate the kind words you got
it uh do I sound bigger and stronger
great as usual yes yes I'm hoping you
can hear my musculature
um how are things I heard y'all at
earthquake y'all are all good
we did we had actually in the middle of
a podcast we had a guest come in from
out of out of state so it was his first
time experiencing an earthquake scared
him a little bit did y'all uh I could
just imagine the Mind pump dude y'all
just all held hands and flexed real hard
and the Earth just stood still is that
how that happened yeah no no freaked out
that's what happened
awesome okay so since we've um last been
in touch uh since we last we're together
in California
I have to tell you man the maps anabolic
has been transformative for me
um it's been it's been nothing short of
magic and I've worked out my whole life
um it's very special and I can tell the
thoughtful and scientific way you'll put
this thing together this isn't just a
cobble together email and then y'all got
a new thing out that's going to help the
really busy single moms and the cops who
don't have much time it's going to help
what I consider regular human beings
um talk about what you just put out and
talk about the benefits and everything
about it yeah absolutely
um so the biggest challenge by far when
it comes to fitness and exercise for
most people okay so now I'm talking to
the average person is really about
consistency and and consistency is the
biggest challenge lots of people get
started with workouts but it's very hard
to do it on a consistent month after
month year after year basis and one
thing that we figured out as trainers
you know we trained everyday regular
people for over two decades was that
people were actually more consistent if
you gave them short workouts to do every
day versus longer workouts to do less
frequently so for example instead of
doing two let's say one hour workouts a
week
um 15 minutes every single day people
just found it easier to be consistent
it's easier to find the time
it's uh you get the ball rolling you
practice this good relationship with
exercise on a regular basis you develop
this better relationship faster as a
result of that you don't beat yourself
up in the workout
um which that tends to be a more
challenging relationship to build is
like pain that you feel from working out
well 50 minutes you tend to feel a
little less pain but it's also just uh
as effective a lot of people think well
is this going to be as effective as you
know going to the gym a few days a week
yes it is it's uh the same amount of
volume same amount of reps you're just
breaking it up on a on a daily basis and
when it comes to strength training in
particular all you need to do is send
the signal to your body so that it can
change so that the actual progress that
your body makes with the workout is not
in the workout it's the signaling
process and then it's afterwards when
your body's actually starting to adapt
and change and get stronger and then of
course from that process you get a
faster metabolism makes it easier for to
get lean and all that stuff so what we
did is we put together a workout program
that's 15 minutes today it uses a
suspension trainer and a pair of
dumbbells so you can literally hang the
suspension trainer in your in your
doorway like a TRX kind of thing
exactly so TRX would be the brand name
of what a suspension trainer right okay
okay and you just you just jump on there
you do two or three exercises and the
workouts are all mapped out for you and
planned with Demos in the whole deal and
um and you work out and what we're
finding is exactly what we found when we
train clients which is and this is just
people now are messaging us saying this
is the most consistent I've ever been
with workouts my body's changing I don't
realize that I could get results doing
you know something like this
and it's um it's a game changer and
again if you could solve the consistency
issue you've solved the fitness problem
and uh that's what we're attempting to
do with this and it's it's it's working
out pretty well well let me add another
layer to it
um
I'm not proud of this but I'm somebody
for years who has
if I've got 40 minutes in the morning
and
um
my son who's 12 is getting up to go to
school
one day a week we go to breakfast
together but the other days a week I
could be sitting upstairs having
breakfast with my son listening to him
talk about his day how are things going
and I'm always in the basement at the in
the gym working out because I'm going to
get my 45 or 50 minutes in and so
um you sent me this right as right
before it launched and I've been
utilizing it at home and it just so
happened a month after I got home from
California I signed up and uh we mapped
out and I'm working on another big book
I've hit the road follows my busy travel
schedule for Live Events I'm all over
the place
and suddenly
I don't have the time and so here's what
this thing has given me the consistency
was was less of an issue and I know
that's harder for for what I would say
average people but people who aren't
psychotic like I am
but this has given me time back with my
family Sal and it's given me it's
helping me be a better husband and a
better dad because in this wild season
I'm in I don't have an hour that doesn't
come at the cost of something that is
probably more important existentially
and so I want to say thank you for
giving me a program I'm still sweating
and I'm still I'm making it as hard as I
can in that 15-20 minutes and I'm using
it but it's given me
the most precious resource I have on the
planet it's not renewable which is time
especially with my little ones man so
thank you for putting this out there
what are you hearing from from people
who use this as they're coming back what
are you hearing well there's two two
types of people that'll typically that
have been messaging us the first one is
the person that does have the challenges
with consistency and they're sending us
emails saying this is I I've never been
this consistent it feels like I'm
developing a behavior this is definitely
something I can continue long term and
then we have the the skeptical Advanced
you know person who's been working out
for a long time who didn't think that
their body would respond training in
this particular way and and I'd like to
for those people I'd like to point to
the data that you we have on Olympic
weightlifters and strength athletes I
mean the Soviets back in the day figured
this out that short frequent workouts
were more effective than long in
frequent workouts infrequent I should
say workouts when it came to getting the
body to progress and again I want to
hammer this home it's not the how many
calories you burn in the workout it's
not it's not the workout itself that's
giving you the value it's what what it
does to your body how it signals that
adaptation process so so that's how we
probably around the world that's how all
workouts should be programmed really bad
workouts are written in ways to make you
feel sore and like it's really hard and
you might get results initially and then
you figure out and then you can't figure
out why your body plateaued it's because
they don't focus on the adaptation
process it's all about just making you
feel like you're getting a good workout
in the workout itself we don't write
programs that way you know we like I
said we train people people for a long
time and for us it's all about results
and then you said one more thing John
I'd like to add which is you know and
this is uh such a key thing you don't
people most people don't live to work
out I mean you could be a fitness
fanatic and it could be your your job I
guess
um but most people want to work out to
live better that's really what it should
be all about and that's how you develop
that long term forever relationship is
do my workouts give me more time do they
improve the quality of my life do I have
more energy so it's really about
improving the quality of your life not
living to work out so that's what this
program is really all about I love it
and uh I'll speak to those folks who are
already go to the gym a lot and they
they kind of like the old way of doing
work like I'm the first gen in the last
out I was here longer than anybody else
when and now we all realize well golf
clap do congratulations for Galatians
like did you get the job done and how
effective were you I don't care how long
you sat there so some of us get our um
our self-esteem boosted a little bit by
how long we're in the gym or whatever I
will speak to
um a this program's written in a way
that I can
I can modulate up if I need it to be a
little more aggressive or if I just need
to get to to blow it out a bit I can I
can modulate it up I can no one's
stopping me from staying an extra five
or ten minutes
and if I do it right and I follow the
clock I'll leave I can I can believe
pretty gassed right it's it's I'm not I
don't feel like I'm skimping on anything
and in fact
um there's been a couple of times the
last few weeks when I would have just
skipped I would have skipped and I would
have gone to work and knocked it out and
uh I would have gone to work and just
skipped for the day and I went ahead
downstairs and knocked it out so
um man oh man oh man okay so where do
people go get this
um wait let's back up tell them about
real quick tell them about your the maps
architecture like what is the program
what is it which ones exist and then
tell them where they can go get this
Maps 15 the new program yeah yeah so
Maps is an acronym that stands for
muscular adaptation programming system
and all of our programs we kind of
create this Avatar
um and we try to write workout programs
that really are the most effective that
require the least amount of work to
produce the most amount of results
that's really what it's all about um you
know if if you need to dig a hole why
use a spoon when you can use a shovel
right so trying to make them just as
effective as possible with the amount of
time that people will spend doing them
so we have a lot of maps programs we
have some that are extremely Advanced
like if you're like a competitive level
bodybuilder or power lifter or you do uh
obstacle course racing and then we have
programs for total beginners we have
programs like Maps 15 which is really
about tackling that consistency issue
which we think Maps 15 is going to be
the one that and it's already turning
out to be the most popular program that
we've ever uh created that's right all
of these programs you can find them at
mapsfitnessproducts.com and then you can
see the name and you could kind of hover
over and watch the videos and kind of
get the explanation as to what the
program's about and kind of figure out
which one's for you and there's a chat
function there where you can ask
somebody if you really need help on you
know figuring out because the right
workout will do the best for the right
person so you want to find the right one
for you always that's fantastic well
um
on behalf of just regular moms and dads
I want to thank you thank you and your
whole team for putting this together for
putting it out there I want to thank you
personally for your time this morning
thank you for the impact you've had on
my on my family and for putting the
stuff in a way that even a guy who
thought he knew everything about it um
has I've had a lot to learn and a lot to
unlearn really
um and thank you for the continued
message you guys are putting out into
the world to reshape the re retake the
health and fitness industry man and make
it digestible and make it actually
applicable to people who are hurting out
there I'm really grateful for the work
you and your gang are doing
I appreciate that John and I do want to
add uh one thing is um it's quite
humbling to meet somebody like you I
mean what you said in the beginning is
100 true this is not a paid sponsorship
or advertising you called us
and just really liked what we did and
wanted us on your show and uh I really
don't I've never really met anybody
uh quite like that um so I appreciate
you're very genuine and honest um and
that's just for your audience to know
like this guy's he's the real deal
um he really cares about people and and
if you know he finds value he wants to
pay people back so you're uh you've made
impacts on us too John so I appreciate
it I'm grateful my brother
um stay in school don't do drugs all
that stuff and give Justin a hug because
he needs one for sure for sure man uh
hey I appreciate y'all much and um
Everybody Maps 15 go to maps
fitnessproducts.com you can go to mind
pump and scroll down and find it Maps
15. if you are stressed if you are busy
if you are trying to figure out dude I
want to get into this Weight Workout
thing that delony's always talking about
I don't know how to do it I don't even
know where to start
um I can't think of a better place to
send you
um go to Maps 15 again
no partnership here no money is
exchanging hands this is me telling you
this has impacted me and my family and I
know it will positively impact you and
yours we'll be right back
it seems like everybody's talking about
how crazy the housing market is right
now and how powerless home buyers feel
mix that with the stress of moving and
life change and job change and you've
got a tornado of anxiety fueling one of
the biggest purchases you'll ever make
this is not a good idea so if you're a
new home buyer right now my advice to
you is to focus on what you can control
like the people you choose to help you
in the home buying process you need
folks like my friends at Churchill
Mortgage Churchill is a Ramsay trusted
provider that's been helping people with
their home mortgages for decades and
their home buyer Edge program will help
you skip a bunch of the stress here's
how it works apply to become a Churchill
certified home buyer and cap your
interest rate for 90 days then you'll
get a five thousand dollar seller
guarantee to help your offer stand out
so go ahead take a deep breath because
Churchill has your back check them out
at churchillmortgage.com deloney and get
the home buyer Edge today this is a paid
advertisement in MLS ID 1591 nmls
consumeraccess.org Equal Housing lender
1749 Mallory Lane Suite 100 Brentwood
Tennessee 37027 programs are for select
loan types only not available in all
states or locations
all right we are back let's go out to
Phoenix Arizona and talk to John what's
up John Phoenix
hey how's it going John I'm good my
brother what's up
um so I I just went through a really
really uh nasty divorce um I'm a
Christian Christian guy I'm 34 years old
um I had a child with my
um
ex-wife
um there's kind of a lot of trauma kind
of built in all of us so forgive me if I
get a little emotional but good man um
our child had had like uh had major
medical issues um when they were born
um we were still married at the time we
got home and she
uh me and her long story short disagreed
about covid about you know I I was
trying to work and provide for my family
and I had them go in and meet my client
and
um she took uh took our child that day
and separated left
um we we had had problems you know in
the rest of the year too but sorry I'm
kind of running around but I'm sorry man
it's a full back story
um so my question is I divorce is
finalized I have 50 50 and I am owing
her still child support and I am having
a really hard time
um just not just dealing with everything
it's just like financially it's also
kind of a burden and I'm I'm just
struggling I've been you know I'm trying
to find like a Biblical approach or a
way to look at it where
um it doesn't cause any more you know
anger hurt and resentment you know
toward her but I'm just I'm really
frustrated that
um like I did not file you know she left
she filed and I feel like no I'm getting
punished forever with this and I just
don't know
I don't know if I'll be able to say but
for a house I don't know if I'll ever be
able to
have like a great you know lifestyle
while having a be a single dad pay for
all the EXP like I still have to pay for
child care on my side and I'm just she
has a bunch of family here and I'm you
know paying and she could work but she's
not and
I just don't know what to do
I can hear it on you man and I
I am heartbroken that your marriage
didn't make it
um I would be willing to bet there was
challenges that covet was not the first
thing that happened
um 100 there was probably some really
heaviness in the water that made the
coven became the lightning rod or became
the focal point and it's not uncommon
unfortunately that kids with special
needs the kids with exceptional medical
issues
um split husbands and wives up because
the grieving process is so unique to
individuals and someone's like why can't
believe you're not concerned about this
or I can't believe you you're just gonna
go watch a movie when our kid is right
and then the other one is like you
expect me to shut down my light right
and people just go to war
um and it really again it's kind of like
money
um the the kid who's struggling is
really the symptom not the issue right
the issue is below that but here you are
you found yourself there
um I think
um I mean I may get my dates off I think
it's 75 76 77 something like that was
when
um the whole like child support came in
to be right and it was the idea of it
was trying to keep the nuclear Kelly
will you check on that like the origin
of Child Support
um but the idea was
still then in the 70s there was a
nuclear family generally speaking mom
stayed home
um Dad work and it was a way to keep the
family looking like it originally did
1950 okay okay
um so I was off 25 years so that's about
right on the show uh 1950. the idea was
we're going to keep the nuclear family
looking as close as possible so mom is
still going to stay home with the kids
that check is still going to show up
here and dad is was usually the one that
chose to leave okay so there's it's it
still has some Shadows to that
um here's the hard reality
I'm gonna say y'all and I know that your
response is going to be that's not true
I didn't file okay but I'm gonna say
y'all on purpose and feel free to push
back when I get done saying what I'm
gonna say okay
okay you all entered into a marriage
and you entered into a legal marriage
and y'all for whatever reason made
decisions
whether on the front end in the middle
on the back end or finally with your
with your XY filing you all made choices
to not handle the disagreements or
handle the relational matters yourself
and because you entered into a legal
Arrangement the dissolution of that
legal Arrangement put the here's what's
going to happen in the hands of a
government official in the hands of a
judge
and the judge made their choice
and what I would tell you is any
anger rage frustration any of the I'm
gonna
that's a choice you are making to be
miserable in the present
any time you spent thinking well she
could be working and she should have
been
that's a choice to be miserable in the
present
and it's something you gotta grieve it's
okay to be frustrated about it it's okay
to be angry about it
all the all your feelings everything's
okay
the reality is the judge spoke
the judge made a declaration a divorce
decree was signed and regardless of what
you think should have happened or I
think it is it's just an is you can go
hire a lawyer or somebody to tell you
that I'll go fight this for you and you
can spend ten thousand or twenty
thousand bucks trying to get another
200 reduced from your total bill every
month you can do that
here is where I would focus my energy in
your situation
I would focus my energy on making sure
that me because you're gonna have a
relationship with this woman for the
rest of your life
forever when your kids get married she's
gonna be there when your kids are in the
hospital she's gonna be you're going to
have a relationship with her forever
the sooner you can make peace with not
her we're not gonna be best friends
we're gonna be lovers again but we're
going to be adults in a relationship for
the rest of our lives we gotta act like
adults that means I'm gonna have to put
my anger and rage down
because it's what's best for these kids
and the sooner she can do that too y'all
can begin to co-parent these kids in a
way that is going to keep it's going to
minimize the divorce trauma it's going
to minimize The Angst and frustration
and yelling they've absorbed for the
last one two three however many years
and so honestly man I think your energy
is best spent
looking forward if I've got to get
another job I got another job if I have
to get a supplemental job for a season I
got to get a supplemental job first he
start being about Solutions and not
sitting in this
so I just threw a lot at you and this is
just me talking to my buddy over a drink
you know at a local joint like tell me
what you think what you're feeling when
I say that stuff
no I I I kind of I'm agreeing and
there's some things I'm also not like on
the same so
she has a great career too so I'm not
not trying to like circumvent that I'm
trying to part part of this
there's a lot of backstory too on this
there were um false allegations made
um against me that I had to uh basically
you know go in with my attorney and
thankfully there were a bunch of cameras
everything I was innocent but I was
you know basically blamed falsely and
when I went in there and
proved that
um the judge made it to me where me and
her can never communicate again except
by email okay
um they were that bad so her her family
um her sister testified like you know in
court we proved it wrong her sister went
to jail for a while okay there so for
perjury heavy
yes
really sorry for lying I'm I'm sorry
maybe not perjury lying under lying
under oath yes
what do they accuse you of
um they said that I went over there and
I was just I was trying to see my son
and they were not letting um I was
seeing him and she started
uh basically yelling at me asking me to
leave and I tried to leave with my son
there was
um unfortunately some physical stuff
that happened between her father and I
and they called the police and the
police came over
um out after the fact and there there
was a camera right across the street
that captured everything outside with me
trying to leave with my son and the
whole conflict and everything and
um her sister and her made all these
other claims that were not even remotely
true and so
um but I was
you you thought you thought you heard
your father-in-law
yeah how was that yeah
I
yeah I I I just it was um I shouldn't
laugh about it but it was no I'm trying
to bring the attention here I can hear
it on you man so
um yeah I know there's millions of guys
who are like I bet I could take that old
man and then that old man's like I've
got dads drink I I might not be able to
wipe properly for the next six months
but I will win this fight right now
right so anyway you did it you actually
fought your father-in-law so there you
go man there you go I got it I got a
couple good licks in and but they yeah
so then they wouldn't let me they made
you know there's a whole bunch of other
stuff that happened okay so so let's you
know what you're telling me is perfect
because here here's the deal
there is such an emotional charge here
there's literally physical altercations
that happen there was lying there's
somebody in jail now there was all kinds
of allegations that were just completely
bogus nonsense
and yet here we are
here we are
and you're looking at this decree
she might be an attorney that makes five
hundred thousand dollars a year
your ex-wife and you might be a plumber
and you make 52.
none of that matters man
the paper says you got to help out with
child support I'm just going to help out
with child support man
what I would much rather have is a
20-year record
for my son when my son turns 30
and I'm just assuming your kids I don't
know how old your kid is but
um I want my kid when they turn 25
to have a record of dead never missed
because the truth will come out by the
way and if your ex-wife is someone who
lies someone who weaponizes her child
someone who demonizes
it will it will it will resurface and
what you're doing now relational is
you're playing a 15 or 20 or 30 year
game with your with your son
okay
the truth will will be known and there
will be a 20-year or an 18-year however
long I guess it's going to be an eight
year
um but it will be an eight-year
um record dad never missed a payment
this wasn't about supporting mom this
wasn't about trying to prop her this is
about taking care of my baby
I always showed up I always showed up
and that's what we're playing a
forward-looking game NADA can you
believe this all happened again because
if you go back to court it's not about
your kid it's about you think you got
beat in court and you don't think you
should have lost
yeah I'm sorry just to I'll say this
really quick I don't feel that way I
feel what just
I got 50 50. I am so grateful John for
that I know there's a lot of good Dads
that got you know traditionally in the
past right had did not get that and
they're with these other these these
allegations and stuff that were I mean I
thought I was never going to see him
again you know sorry for a little
emotional I mean I thought I was done
and thankfully you know God there were
things set in place so I can see him and
be in his life and I you know I'm not
quitting on him I love him and well I
know you're not I know you're not
struggling because you know
it's just it like I'm just looking at
I'm like well we got 50 50. why am I she
has a a great career why am I giving her
anything like why can we not just split
this for him down the middle amicably
and I just don't understand why I'm
getting the
and what I would say is I totally get
the struggle and mathematically that
struggle makes sense philosophically
that struggle makes sense
but when y'all two chose
her maybe more than you okay maybe way
more than you but when you all chose to
not be able to reconcile your challenges
together
you offloaded that responsibility to a
third party and that third party made
their choice
and so we're sitting in the middle of
that choice
we were sitting in the middle of that
decision
and if she goes back to work
then you might have a court case
if she's staying at home because of the
trauma of her husband ex-husband was so
dude I'm gonna write my check I'm going
to love the snot out of that kid
and then I'm going to go make my career
the best it can be I'm going to engage
in relationships that are good for me
that are healthy for me and I'm going
forward man
I'm going forward
okay any choice to hang around with that
past is a choice to be weighed down
and it's gonna feel like lightning bolts
the rage
you're gonna have something cool come up
and you're gonna have just written how
how much is the check
um it is about 400 a month okay
um it's not it's so I'll just say this
it's not even so much the
I make a pretty good living and so but
she does as well and I'm just frustrated
because I feel like
not to keep going back but I'm like it
should be 50 50. I don't feel like yep
you know and you're gonna look listen
you're gonna get stuck on the loop
you're gonna get stuck on the loop on
the loop on the loop on the loop on the
loop
it should be and it's not
kids should not get cancer and they do
my buddies shouldn't have gotten a car
wreck and died
he did
and he did
there's so much of our lives that
shouldn't that is
you
um had somebody try to destroy your life
and take your son away from you
and it didn't happen
and
but you do have to pay 400 bucks a month
probably shouldn't have to but it is it
is
and so cool I'm gonna write that four
dollar check and I refuse I refuse
to give her another
room in my head rent free
to to take joy from my life
I refuse I'm not going to give her that
here's your 400.
love my son the best you can I'm I'm on
I'm on to the next with my day
and the loop will start the lightning
bolts will pop in your head when you're
writing that check you'll be so mad or
when that check gets just taken out of
your account you'll get angry and that's
when you have a choice to make am I
going to meditate on this that's 50
freaking 50 and they shouldn't or am I
going to Exhale through and go I'm so
grateful that I don't have to worry at
all that my son's got the financial
resources he needs
now I'm going to the gym now I'm calling
my buddy now I'm going to fill in the
blank whatever else comes next
you see what I'm saying this is a total
reorientation of your life
yeah yeah okay
every time one of those things pop in
your head I keep a journal I write it
down like look it's right here dude I
put like cool tough stickers on it and
stuff so I look all hard
um but it's really just like a diary
it's and it's I got it Walmart
write them down we were frustrated when
you're upset
and then be as adult as an adult as an
adult as you can be on the other side of
it and be about what can I can control
here I can't control the 400 bucks cool
I'm gonna write my four dollar check I'm
gonna move on
and then I'm gonna be about you can save
up for a house
you can
you can work really hard for the next 18
months on a promotion you can work
really hard to get some new skills you
can work really hard on moving to
another career another job you can do
those things you'll get a house
you're absolutely get a house it's gonna
be awesome
you need to pay for half of it in cash
right you're gonna you're gonna be able
to work that stuff out right now you're
still in the Aftershock of
the breakup of your marriage you never
saw yourself as a single dad you never
saw yourself as a d as someone who got
gets divorced you never saw yourself as
someone who failed you never saw you so
you gotta have to reconcile with this
whole new you
and you can
and you will because you're a person you
care
live moving forward
unchain yourself in the past my brother
we'll be right back
hey deloney here one of the things I
love about my job is answering the tough
questions people have when they call
into the show your stories are
incredible in each person's situation is
unique and for years people from all
over the world have been asking if I do
private counseling or private coaching
sessions for them or for their spouse
and as much as I'd love to I can't
realistically do one-on-one coaching
sessions with every single person it's
just not possible but that's exactly why
I wrote my new book own your past change
your future within the pages of this
book is exactly what I would say if you
and I were sitting down together at a
table looking for the next right move
for you to make in your relationships or
to help you live a more whole and
peaceful life as you read through each
section of this book I will show you how
to look and own the roads from your past
and head to the New Roads of a well life
moving forward go to John deloney.com to
get your copy today that's own your past
change your future at John deloney.com
all right as we wrap up today's show hey
we ended up with like a great studio
audience out there everybody partying
here at the ram Solutions headquarters
man it's good to see y'all y'all most of
y'all
not you most of y'all are beautiful and
I'm just kidding you all look great
that's good to see everybody even the
vests look at that we have a vest crew
back there it's fantastic all right uh
we wrap up today's show it's from the
great journey the song's called separate
ways World apart and it goes like this
here we stand Worlds Apart Hearts broken
in two two sleepless nights losing
ground I'm reaching for you you you
and they over uh rhymed that one feeling
like it's gone can't change your mind if
we can't go on to survive the tides love
divides
[Music]
if you must go I wish you luck You'll
Never Walk Alone take care my love miss
you well I don't miss you because you're
coming back we'll see you soon right
here on the Dr John alone show
[Music]